clashes between protesters and the
police
have been ongoing in haiti for the past
weeks
the opposition in the country says
president's joven elmoy's mandate
ended on february 7th while the
government says
it has one more year left the discussion
is over when his term began moise took
office in 2017
because of the political instability in
the country but protesters say the
constitution says something else
al jazeera spoke to foreign minister
khloe joseph
over the political crisis in the
caribbean nation there are large sectors
in the country that that say that what's
happening
now is illegal and the president said
that there was an attempt on his life
that
a coup was being set up in haiti three
judges from the supreme court were
removed one of them
was detained so is haiti's democracy at
risk
haiti is not a democracy at risk
what the government is trying to do
and we are doing our atmos to keep it
is to preserve democracy in haiti
uh we have seen over and over
how uh some politicians
in some oligarchs are trying
to use all illegal means
to actually claim power in haiti so this
is exactly what is going on now but
foreign minister yo
you're talking about oligarchs and about
how they handle power in haiti but when
you look at the streets of haiti
the people that are on those streets
demanding change demanding action
criticizing the president are actually
demanding that their lives improve i
mean they're not oligarchs i mean what
do you say to them
no they are not oligarch and all
democracy it's not only here
in the united states in a great
democracy
how you can call it you have people
uh protesting and some of them
are not i should say use
violent means but the interesting thing
here is that
the government is paying attention
to what the people are asking they are
asking
for their life to be improved those are
legitimate concerns and we agree and the
government
is working on that president joven elmoy
says
he will call for a referendum that will
lead to the reform of haiti's
constitution
and says legislative and presidential
elections will happen this year the
international community
including the oas and the us seem to
support the president's move
on the streets discontent is on the rise
and people say they will make sure
they won't be ignored al jazeera